- I don't look anything
like all the children
that the children like.
- I kind of look close,
just here childish.
(upbeat music)
- Today, we're taking a Buzzfeed quiz.
We're here with Anna Akana.
Anna, tell us about yourself.
- Hi, I am an actor and I make the videos
and my show, Youth and Consequences,
comes out on YouTube Red on March 7th.
- So this quiz we're taking is called
Sorry Millennials, only Gen
Zer's are passing this quiz.
- Not Jen's Ears as in Jenny's earlobes.
- Jen's ears.
- Gen Z is what age, when were they born?
- 2000's.
- Year of the Dragon?
Certainly below millennials.
- Below millennials.
The first question is, which one
of these is the app musical.ly?
Don't know.
- I've made a few musicl.ly's.
I tried to get into it.
I wanted to know what it was like.
I only did the song Why
Not by Hillary Duff.
- I contemplated making
a musical.ly just 'cause
I heard about it, and then I was like,
I'm not going to do that.
- Yeah, no, you made
the right choice not to.
It was a dark time for me.
♪ Why not take a crazy chance ♪
♪ Why not do a crazy dance ♪
- I'm gonna guess it's
this top orange one.
Nope.
- [Keith] I'm gonna go
with the microphone.
- You are both wrong.
It is the red circle
with the squiggly line.
It's like a little snake inside.
- Cool.
- Yes, super cool.
- Who is this, and it's a picture
of sort of a cherub-looking boy.
- Little elf.
- [Keith] His hair is half
the height of his face.
- What does this say about
me that I know who this is?
What?
- I know who it isn't.
It's not Shane Dawson, not Connor.
So he's either gotta be
an Austin or a Jacob.
- He looks like an Austin to me.
- I think, but he could also be a Jacob.
- I'm just gonna (pops)
- I'm gonna say Austin.
- I'll say Jacob.
- You were right, it is Jacob Sartorius.
I'm just gonna be the expert here.
You guys take the quiz and I'll tell--
- How old are you, why
are you acing all of this?
- I'm actually 10 years old.
You know what's worse is that
I don't just know who this is.
I know who he's dating.
He's dating Eleven from Stranger Things.
And I know she's a child,
but I'm just gonna go ahead
and say it, he doesn't
seem like the right guy.
Millie, I think you can do better.
What movie is this quote from?
And so the lion fell
in love with the lamb.
- Oh, I know this, please.
- It's probably Twilight.
- It's not Easy A, it's not The Notebook.
Yeah, but there's not lions.
I'm gonna go Hunger Games.
- I'm going Twilight.
- You're wrong, it's Twilight.
I was a big fan of Twilight.
- But there's no lion.
- It's a metaphor.
- 'Cause he's a vampire
and she's his food.
- Get it?
What are these called?
And it appears to be
some sort of rubber band
in the animal shape.
- Those are fun.
- A duck, a pig, a turtle, a cat.
- Is it Crazy Bandz, Silly Bandz,
Wacky Bandz, or Rubber Bandz?
- Ooh boy.
- I think they're Silly Bandz.
- They're pretty silly
looking, they're also--
- But they're also regular animals.
- Yeah, 'cause they're not,
I would say they're not too wacky.
I think that they show that the person
who wears them is just a little silly.
So I'm gonna go with Keith.
- Yeah, I think it's Silly Bandz.
(all cheer)
Silly Bandz.
- Being a sheep paid off.
What was Zendaya's first
Disney Channel show called?
- I didn't know she was
on a Disney Channel show.
- I was on this show.
- Well that's not fair.
I think it's not Shake It.
- Mm-mm, too simple.
- I think it's not Shake It Off.
- I'm gonna go with Shake It Up.
- I think it's Stop, Drop
and Dance or Shake It Up.
You can't answer.
It's about a girl in high
school and she dances, I'm sure.
Right, she's a high
school girl who dances?
- Pretty wrong, pretty wrong.
- What, what could it possibly be?
- She's in middle school and she dances.
- Oh, farts.
If she's in middle school, I'm
gonna say it's Shake It Up.
- Yay, Shake It Up.
- Way to go, Zendaya.
- Yep.
- Oh, this looks like a fun show.
- Demi Lovato famously dated which
of her Disney Channel costars?
- I know this one.
- I got this one.
- I don't know this,
I don't know this one.
- I actually know this.
How thrilling for me.
- I'm the only person
who doesn't know this?
I love Demi Lovato too.
- I know this from meeting Demi Lovato,
not from knowing about her.
- Oh, the casual name drop.
- I did a video with her, and
we called him in the video.
- Dammit.
I think it's gotta be one of the Jonases.
- Yeah, its from the
Camp Rock days, for sure.
- Was it Joe or was it Nick?
- It's one of the Jonases.
- I'm guessing Nick.
- A bonus Jonas--
you're guessing Nick?
- I think it's Joe.
- It's Joe, it's Joe.
- [Anna] Who is that?
- [Zach] Who he?
- [Keith] Who he?
- Is this Travis Squat?
(all laugh)
- It's not Travis Squat.
- Is this Travis Squat?
- Is it Travis Scott, Mil, Lil
Uzi, I can't speak anymore.
- [Keith] Lil Uzi Vert,
Kendrick Lamar, or Quavo?
- It's not Kendrick Lamar.
- That's the only thing I know.
- You wanna divide and conquer here?
- Yeah, I'm gonna guess Travis.
- I think you're right.
I'm gonna go with Quavo.
- I'm going with Lil Uzi Vert.
- Let's see.
Eh, Lil Uzi Vert.
- [Zach] I still don't--
- Don't know who that is.
- That doesn't mean more to me though.
- [Anna] What band are these boys from?
Oh no, I don't know.
- Is this Why Don't We, One Direction,
5 Seconds of Summer, or The Vamps?
You know what?
I think I got this one.
- It's definitely not One Direction.
They're very pale, so
maybe they're The Vamps.
- They look like vampires,
but vampires wouldn't
out themselves like that.
- But Why Don't We also
sounds super creepy and gross
for a teen boy band.
- I hate myself for the reason
that I think I know this, is that
I'm pretty sure Why Don't We sang a song
with Logan Paul, and it was
in a music video with him
and trending and I remember that they were
impossibly young boys and
I thought it was weird
that they were hanging
out with Logan Paul.
- They kind of do look impossibly young.
- So I think that these
children are Why Don't We.
- You're right.
You know everything
about hip new children.
- I'm trying to keep up
with the kids, you know?
- What does this emoji mean
when it appears next to
a friend on Snapchat?
You've been snap BFFs for two months,
you're number one snap BFFs,
you have a snapstreak going,
or you've been snap BFFs for two weeks?
- The only one I know is snap streak,
I believe, is a fire,
a little flame symbol.
- That would make sense, or
lightning bolt or something.
- Yeah.
I guess I'm just wondering,
these two hearts, is
that bigger or smaller
than a heart, than just a regular heart?
- It's smaller, I think it's underplayed
because they're two small hearts.
- This is really stressing me out.
- Man, I should've gone to college.
- I couldn't care less.
I don't care at all.
- I'm gonna guess two weeks.
- I'm going two months.
- Number one snap BFFs.
- Whoo, I'm king of the teens.
- Well, you're king of the teens.
- How many did you get right?
- Nine out of 15, you're both
a millennial and a Gen Zer.
Likely a late '90s baby.
Nope, I was '89.
- I got eight out of 15, it also thinks
I'm a late '90s baby,
but I was an '87 baby.
And I don't know enough, Zach?
- I'm also likely a late '90s baby,
but I got 10 out of 15
right, I am a child.
This is the worst and most
hollow victory in my entire life.
- Yeah.
- Thanks for watching.
- What do you think
about Millie Bobby Brown
and Jacob Sartorius dating?
Let us know in the comments below.
I think they should break up.
(upbeat music)